So we just identified which
graph actually met our criteria,
of going through a point and
having a certain slope.
But how do I generate that graph myself?
Well let's say that a line goes through
the point negative two, five and
has a slope of negative three-fourths.
Well, my first step is to find
the point negative two, five.
Negative one, negative two and
then up one, two, three, four, five.
Now my next step is to obey
the commands given by the slope.
To find the next point,
by finding which point would have a rise
of negative three and a run of four.
So can you tell me what's the next
point that I should plot?
And you can just click
the appropriate place on the graph.